[Music]
good afternoon thank you for coming I am
Robert Spencer the director of jihad
watch and the associate director of the
American Freedom Defense Initiative
which has produced the
documentary about to see about uh 10
minutes of and then we will be showing
the full piece tomorrow at
11:00 and so be sure to come to see the
world premiere of the documentary The
Ground Zero mosque the second wave of
the 911 attacks today we'll be hearing
from 911 family members who are here
with us on the deis and we will be
discussing the issue of the ground zero
mosque and its significance I thought
just very briefly I would explain why
this movie has this strange title which
some people have actually told us they
find that offensive how could The Ground
Zero MOS be the second wave of the 9/11
attacks look at
history all through the world whenever
Islamic jihadists conquered a land they
would then build a mosque of Triumph to
mark their Conquest the most notorious
example is when they overwhelmed overran
Jerusalem in the year 636 and very
shortly thereafter built the aloa mosque
and then the Dome of the Rock on the
site of the Jewish temple in Jerusalem
those mosques Were Meant to Mark the
superiority of Islam over Judaism and
the Triumph of
Islam there are thousands of mosques
like that all over the world thousands
built on the sites of destroyed Hindu
temples synagogues and Christian
churches or actual converted buildings
that once were Hindu temples synagogues
and churches are now
mosques all of them are understood
universally in the Islamic world in the
areas where they are as marking the
Triumph and the superiority of Islam now
contrast that to what we have heard
about this Ground Zero mosque that's
going to be built or going to be built
if they get away with it at the site of
the World Trade Center attacks on
September 11th they say the organizers
of the mosque that it is a mosque of
peace and Reconciliation and Harmony
that is designed to build Bridges with
non-muslims now what they say is what
they say the question is how do the does
the large majority of Muslims understand
what they're doing if you go around the
world and count how many mosques of
peace and Reconciliation have been built
at the sight of previous Jihad attacks
in order to reach out to those
associated with the victims how
many zero none never happened before in
1400 years of Islam how many triumphal
mosques built to to to celebrate a
victory of Islam thousands which do you
think people will understand this mosque
to be the average Muslim on the street
and then he will be more emboldened he
will say America is weak America is
conquered America is ripe for the
plucking this mosque will be the single
most encouraging development for the
Islamic Jihad since 9/11 itself and
that's why it's the second wave and so
thank you all very much for coming and
now
our favorite and esteemed director of
the American Freedom Defense
Initiative Pamela Geller will explain
further
[Applause]
[Music]